Throughout this rest of this lesson, you'll learn to interact with pandas and
numpy using this medal count data from the 2014 Sochi Winter Olympics.
We have the 26 countries who medal at least once, and how many gold,
silver, bronze, and total medals they earned during the Sochi Olympics.
Create a pandas dataframe called Olympics_medal_counts_df containing the data
from the table of 2014 Sochi winter Olympics medal counts.
The columns for
this dataframe should be called country name, gold, silver and bronze.
There is no need to specify row indices for this dataframe.
In this case, the rows will automatically be assigned numbered indexes.
Your code should go here